result of the cost of living pressures
at the moment and have announced one of
the largest support packages in Europe
worth around 3 300 pounds per household
this year and last
thank you Mr Speaker the latest report
from which highlights that even
supermarkets on budget brands of food
have increased by 26.6 the security
locks on baby formula milk at the same
time as caused by Asians are making vast
profits the governments have signed up
to United Nations sustainable gold and
eradicating poverty by 2030 surely now
is the time in light of these
commitments but the chances to act Willy
cap essential food places and tackle the
growth test profit here and in the food
industry that are thriving many of my
constituents in Liverpool West Derby to
poverty
Chancellor well I totally respect him
for raising the concerns of his
constituents in that way I don't believe
capping prices is the right long-term
solution but we are doing a lot
including payments of 900 pounds per
household for people on means tested
benefits 150 pounds per household for
households with someone disabled living
in them and 300 pounds for households
with pensioners living in them precisely
because we want to help the people that
he's talking about and I will be meeting
The Regulators next week to talk further
about what needs to be done with respect
to supermarkets Trisha Gibson thank you
Mr over the week
of the week or more governor Governor
Bank of England Mark Carney spoke about
how before the brexit referendum the
bank of England had set out that the
likely consequences of brexit where a
weaker pound higher inflation and weaker
growth does the chancellor think it's
fair that the UK government's decision
to ignore and start warnings from the
bank of England are now being paid for
by the households who can at least
afford it
Chancellor I Mr Speaker I'm afraid I
don't buy this uh brexit narrative from
the SMP food price inflation has been
around 20 percent in Germany Sweden
Portugal and Poland in recent times so
this is not a UK specific issue we are
all dealing with the consequences of
Putin's invasion of Ukraine and the
aftermath of the pandemic and we are all
tackling it with one Central Focus which
is to bring down inflation as our
overriding priority Richard Thompson
thank you Mr Speaker the former U.S
treasury Chief said earlier this month
that brexit was a historic economic
error and described the UK government's
economic policies having been
substantially flawed for a number of
years so will the chancellor finally
face up to put the rest of the world
concede and admit that uh leaving the
world's largest single Market has not
only had a significant impact in
inflation but it's also had a
deleterious impact on household finances
across the country
I think the issue with that argument is
that the UK has actually grown faster
than France or Italy since we left the
single market and according to the
managing director of the IMF the UK
economy is on the right track
sir Jake Barry Mr Speaker I want to
thank my right honorable friend for all
he has done for people in Roslindale and
Darwin to help them through this cost of
living crisis but people are very
concerned with what is being described
as the mortgage bomb about to go off
is now the time for him to look at
reintroducing a bold conservative idea
of mortgage interest relief at source
because if we don't help families now
all the other money that we spend to
help them will have been wasted if they
lose their home
well
no one could have a more doubty champion
in Roslindale and Darwin than my right
honorable friend and I listened to what
he says carefully but I think he will
understand that those kind of schemes
which involve injecting large amounts of
cash into the economy right now would be
inflationary so much as we sympathize
with the difficulties we'll do
everything we can to help people seeing
their mortgage costs go up we won't do
anything that would mean we prolonged
inflation smps spokesperson Stuart he'll
say is to speak of the cost of a
two-year fixed mortgage in March 2021
was 2.57 this week it reached six
percent now given the chancellor and the
economic secretary have said there are
no plans to change the bank of England
inflation Target meaning the base rate
which drives the mortgage rate will
continue to rise as inflation stays
stubbornly high and mortgages will go up
so in the absence of that change what is
it that the government plan to do to
actually tackle the mortgage paying
people are suffering from
Chancellor the first thing I would say
to him is that what he's talking about
is something that's being experienced
across the world and in fact interest
rates have risen faster in the United
States and Canada than they have here
the answer is we'll look at doing
everything we can to help people under
pressure but we won't do things that
will prolong the inflationary Agony that
people are going through and we have to
be very careful because a lot of the
schemes that are being proposed would
actually make inflation worse and not
better
said in March inflation was due to Peak
at 2.9 percent at the end of this year
by May the bank of England the forecast
that it would be five percent at the end
of this year almost double in the space
of two months so given inflation
headline is still what 8.7 food
inflation is 16 and a half percent
will the chancellor guarantee today that
inflation will be halfed to five percent
as promised by the prime minister in
January this year
the IMF the obr and the bank of England
all predict that we will hit our Target
to halve inflation and I give him this
guarantee we will stick to the plan to
do so
right Gerald Jones question three please
Mr Speaker
minister with permission Mr Speaker I'd
like to answer this question together
with questions number nine and ten we
recognize that this is a concerning time
for homeowners and mortgage holders we
can't ignore the fact I just those then
may wish to that interest rates have
risen across Western economies as a
result of the covid pandemic and the
impact of war in Ukraine the bank of
England sets the base rate which can
have an effect on mortgage pricing and
the bank's been independent since the
decision of the then labor government in
1997. we remain committed to responsible
management to bring inflation under
control which is the only sustainable
way to lower interest rates and lower
mortgage rates
thank you Mr get the former prime
ministers apologize for the mistakes in
her so-called growth plan and the Damage
it caused families across the UK will
soon start paying thousands more in
mortgage interests payments and given
the prime minister's comments yesterday
it appears there's little or no further
support come in so will the minister
join the former prime minister and
apologize to the nation for the impact
of the party opposites misguided
economic experience
Mr Speaker much as though the opposition
would prefer this not to be the case
this is the fact uh that is impacting
across Western economies although Market
to Market comparisons are not always
easy uh in the United States of America
the average 30-year mortgage has
increased now to above six percent as I
said previously this government will do
what it can sustainably to lower
interest rates and thereby ease the
burden on our mortgage holders
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker this is
the time I'm putting it to the
government that
I don't think it'll be the last time
either and I say this because the
average interest rate on a new two-year
fixed mortgage is now above six percent
now the chance was already said that
they will do everything they can do but
what does this actually mean because the
public would like to know
Mister thank you very much Mr Speaker I
Thank The Honorable lady for her
question not only are we taking action
taking the duff decisions to uh
sustainably uh improve the nation's
finances but we're also working and the
chancellor and I regularly meet with the
mortgage industry with lenders about the
support that they can provide to
mortgage holders if they do get into
financial difficulties a range of
measures that in could include term
extensions a switch to interest-only
payment holidays and the FCA guidance is
very clear that any repossessions and
they are currently running at a
historical low any repossessions should
be an absolute Last Resort
thank you very much Mr Speaker as a
result of the six percent we've already
held about more than a million
households and flexible rate mortgages
have already faced increases this year
and 1.8 million more will see the fixed
rate more deals come to an end and face
increases in this year and it's not just
home Corners the knock-on effect has
meant that in my constituency in
Edinburgh we've had the highest rental
inflation anywhere in the country at
13.7 percent in the last Financial year
because landowners at sorry uh landlords
are facing increases no mortgages now
the government has said it's willing to
support people so would it be willing to
consider the liberal Democrats idea of a
mortgage protection fund to protect
those on lowest incomes and support
support those who are struggling
uh well I think the honorable member for
Edinburgh East for her question
um
regrettably The Proposal that she and
her party puts forward would not only
delay the point at which we're able to
Bear Down on inflation to deliver the
nation's mortgage holders the lower
interest that they need but it would
also and The Honorable member raise the
point of private renters it would do
nothing as I understand their proposal
for the plight of private renters of the
commitment thank you very much Mr
Speaker and the growth plan in September
obviously did have an impact on the
mortgage Market but is the economic
secretary aware that by November when he
gave evidence to our committee the bank
of England Governor actually said that
uh the increases in mortgages henceforth
were really down to the bank of
England's own increases because that
temporary effect from the growth plan
had dissipated and increases since then
have been largely due to the fact that
inflation has been worse than the bank
was forecasting and did the economic
secretary note that this week I received
a letter from the chair of court at the
bank of England saying that they are
going to undertake uh the request that I
sent them to have a look at their
inflation modeling and why it's been
incorrect
well not for the first time Mr Speaker
the chair of the select committee is on
the money in her understanding of what
is actually driving the markets and her
own advocacy and Champion for the fact
that our lending Banks need to do a good
job not just for mortgage holders but
also for Savers and that's something I'm
very happy to meet with the honorable
lady to talk about how we can do make
sure that they do the best job they can
follow thank you Mr Speaker the minister
in his earlier reply talked about
mortgages in the United States and he
will know that in the United States it
is quite common to fix a mortgage for 15
or 30 years which gives certainty about
monthly repayments and of course can be
refinanced if mortgage rates go down
over the period in terms of the mortgage
I understand that the UK treasury looked
at the UK mortgage market for
introducing such long-term fixed rates
and found that at that time there wasn't
much potential will he consider looking
at that again
understood I Thank The Honorable member
for his uh his question as ever
um opposite when it comes to treasury
matters there are indeed Mr Speaker uh
long-term fixed rate mortgages on the
market
um I have taken advice from officials on
that
um the the constraining factor uh is
actually consumer demand that's not a
pattern of behavior that we've seen but
clearly for some mortgage holders that
does offer the long-term certainty and
it's certainly my objective that we see
the broadest range of choices for
householders for their own individual
fat patterns in the market Jonathan got
it thank you Mr Speaker mortgage payers
in Stoke-on-Trent North kidsgrove and
talk are rightly worried at this moment
in time with the impending uh
rebrokering that they are facing and to
support what my right unfriend the
member for Rosendale and Darwin said
earlier is it not time to return return
to a conservative principle of
introducing a myrist type scheme which
allows borrowers tax relief for interest
payments on their mortgages
well I I always listen enormously
carefully to the very powerful advocacy
uh for Stoke-on-Trent and the fact that
his constituents put their trust in this
government but one of the things that
they put their trust in is that this
government wouldn't come forward with
the sort of unfunded spending
commitments that we see on the benches
opposite that would be disastrous for
his constituents because it would see
inflation be higher for longer show the
minister pack my thumb speaker the only
thing that grew as a result of what the
government did last September was
people's mortgage payments two-year
fixed rates now over six percent
payments uh for householders up 2 900
over the next uh year has the government
learned the lesson from Minister's
decision and I stress decision nothing
to do with international events to use
the country for a giant economic
experiment that heart hormonals pushed
up interest rates and shook
International confidence in the United
Kingdom and if they have will the
minister now apologize to the
householders who are paying the price
for that mistake
as ever right a little very carefully to
the right honorable members rhetoric I'd
ask him if he's heard the lesson that we
saw from the last Labor government that
spent its way spent its way through the
nation's finances and whose most whose
most lasting contribution to the economy
that we inherited was a note from the
previous Chief secretary saying there is
no money left
Mr Speaker back to 2023. this is a real
crisis affecting real people as a result
of his government's real decisions now
figures out today show that the average
UK tenant is spending over 28 of their
income on rent and that rents have gone
up by over 10 in the past year rents are
being forced up because the landlords
that people rent from are seeing their
mortgages go up to sometimes even faster
than mortgages in general now the
chancellor and the Prime Minister were
supposed to be the team that would come
in and sort everything out can the
minister tell us what went wrong
minister
what went right Mr Speaker is the fact
that we on this side of the house not
only will always focus on the stability
of the nation's finances to get
inflation and interest rates falling
further and faster than the opposition
would but also even within that envelope
we found fit to find 3 300 pound on
average of support for households last
winter and the upcoming winter something
that will make a very significant impact
into the difficulties uh that mortgage
holders and renters are facing because
of the higher interest rates that are a
feature Across the Western World Rachel
Hopkins number four
Alice thank you Mr Speaker
um the government undertakes extensive
assessment of the effectiveness of the
sanctioned regimes which are eroding
Russia's Financial base we have 28
Russian Banks covering 80 of Russia's
banking sector uh sanctioned and over 18
billion of Russian assets and
implemented unprecedented trade
sanctions in addition to that
Rachel Hopkins thank you Mr Speaker
constituents in Luton south of raised
concerns about the financial sanctions
regime with me so can the government
confirm if it's still the case that
Russian account holders in the UK can
hold fifty thousand pounds or more in
their accounts and what is to prevent
individuals of concerns simply passing
up assets through proxies into a large
network of accounts below the permitted
level
well the office of financial sanctions
implementation works very closely with
our allies across the G7 to ensure that
we have coordinated action amongst our
International Partners on this
unprecedented package of sanctions we've
Frozen the assets of 1600 individuals
and entities we've implemented 35
different sanction regimes across
government I'd be very happy to address
the specific question she's asked
because obviously that is quite
technical I'm very happy to take it away
for her I've done that thank you Mr
Speaker a multi-million pound startup
project that could be transformational
in my constituency is now at risk
because the office of financial
sanctions implementation is yet to
process an asset-free's license
application in respect of just
.002 of the company's Capital which was
submitted in April what steps is the
minister taking to ensure that such
applications are dealt with swiftly and
if I provide him the details of the
company will he ensure that its progress
is expedited
well I'm very happy to take up my
responsible friends case we have
expanded the off-sea uh resources we
have a monthly monitoring and efficiency
dashboard but I accept very much how
frustrating it can be for constituents
businesses when such situations arise
and I'm very happy to take it away and
swiftly get back to him so the minister
James Murray yeah
Mr Speaker as the war in Ukraine
continues we must not have let up for a
second on efforts to tighten the net on
the accomplices and beneficiaries of
Putin's regime now we welcome the
direction of the measures announced
yesterday so can the minister confirm
whether these measures will close all
loopholes and specifically ownership
thresholds which Russian oligarchs and
their enablers have been able to exploit
to evade the bite of sanctions
Minister what I can say to The Honorable
gentleman this government will be
relentless in its pursuit of illicit
assets we've uh as I said sanctioned 24
banks with global assets of over 940
billion and 120 elites with a combined
net worth of over 140 billion and
working closely with our allies
incrementally and sequentially we've
tightened that net we've immobilized
over 60 percent of Putin's War chest of
foreign reserves worth 275 billion
pounds we continue to work closely with
our allies to intensify those as
opportunities arise
Robert Sims I have one or two
constituents in pool who've lost their
job because they were in companies which
were owned by Russians that were
sanctioned and they've been finding
difficulty having an orderly wind up
because Banks run a mile from learning a
reasonable amount of money to sort out
some of the businesses and I know one
situation where people haven't been able
to get p60s because they haven't been
able to pay the accountants who would
produce them because they can't get
money from any of the banks because they
don't want to be involved in anything to
do with sanctions so perhaps I may have
a word with the individual about that
with the uh with the minister because I
do think
um in some cases we're going over the
top and it's affecting our constituents
Minister well I I thank my honorable
friend for his question I think that the
points raised uh demonstrate how serious
and and extensive the government uh
actions are in regard to this but I
recognize the unfortunate situations
that sometimes arise and I'm very happy
to look at that case and take it back to
obviously thank you Mr Speaker um
pursuing the issue of proxies raised by
my honorable friend the member for loon
South am I right in thinking that the
what the minister said a few minutes ago
was that he was prepared to examine the
possibility of taking action against
proxies and those Persons of Interest
Who use proxies
what I would say is this government is
committed to an Ever tighter grip on
illicit finance and those individuals
close to Putin who make a material
contribution to his regime uh obviously
on the floor of the house I'm not going
to commit to individual extensions to
what we've already done but I've set out
the range of sanction regimes that exist
across multiple Departments of
government and I'm very happy to receive
representations on whatever Casey wishes
to bring to me about Black question
number six Mr Speaker
well my honorable friend is a strong
champion in support of consumers who've
suffered Financial loss particularly
through his chairmanship of the
all-party Parliamentary group on
Personal Banking and fairer Financial
Services he understands that the UK does
not operate a zero loss regime where
consumers uh of financial services are
automatically compensated but it is
important that Regulators make very
clear where the scope of protection lies
and who is eligible for compensation
well Blackman I thank my honorable
friend for that answer and clearly it's
important that where the Ombudsman
recommends that compensation be paid
clearly banks have to do so but equally
the government of course should also pay
compensation when the Parliamentary
Ombudsman found against them in terms of
actual life policy holders as mentioned
by you ought to remember for strangford
I understand that the budget to pay a
compensation to extra life policyholders
is some 300 million pounds under spent
so will he rather than turn the money to
the treasury use that money to
compensate the people that have suffered
in the long term asexual life
policyholders
Mr Speaker we set out the terms of that
settlement in in 2010 and there's
nothing to update the house on today
Nick Smith
Mr Speaker for over five years I've
campaigned on behalf of steel workers
who were part of the British steel
pension scheme many were ripped off by
sharks posing as financial advisors now
whilst the redress scheme is now in
place legal advisors for steel workers
report claim processing delays of six
months at the financial conduct
Authority 12 months at the financial
services compensation scheme and two
years at the financial
ombudsman's service
that's just not right cases being
delayed can have a big impact on
possible payouts so will the minister
please look into the performance of
these organizations steel workers and
other Financial consumers deserve much
better than this
yes I will I've had conversations with
my honorable friend I want to remember
previously about that and I will take up
the case of unwarranted delays if that's
the case those other stuff number eight
with commission Mr Speaker I'd like to
take this with number 15. I've set out
our national ambition to be the world's
next Silicon Valley and we are making
good progress last year being ranked as
the world's third largest technology
market after the United States and China
Alexander staff of thank you speaker
ultimate battery in thurcroft in Rolla
Valley are developing new groundbreaking
bash Technologies and I'm on the track
to create 500 new jobs by 2025. what
help can the minister Department give me
and also my constituents to help
burgeoning technical businesses such as
ultimate power battery to make sure that
Roller Valley and across the north are
technology hubs
Chancellor well I'd like to thank him
for his support in Robert Valley for
this really important sector and we do
have a number of schemes there's 541
million pounds of funding uh in the
Faraday battery challenge that's
available and we also have the one
billion pound Automotive transformation
fund but as a result of the efforts that
he and many others have made we're now
getting 40 percent of our electricity
from renewable sources that's the second
highest in Europe with much more
progress to come more of us thank you Mr
Speaker I recently convened a Roundtable
in my constituency between the science
Minister and a number of Science and
Tech businesses and their number one
asked was what fiscal support was
available for their sector now I'm aware
that there are numerous schemes of
Grants and tax relief but it was notable
to me that this was not well understood
by the businesses and I couldn't find it
published anywhere on the new
department's website either so could I
ask my right honorable friend to put
together and publish a package of all
the support that is available to
investors and to innovators and how that
these can be applied for so that we can
maximize the potential of this vehicle
New Frontier in West Berkshire and
Beyond
um it's a very fair point and I want to
first of all thank her for uh the fact
that Newbury is a hotbed of Technology
businesses I think you've got rock
Technologies Striker Edwards life
sciences and a range of other businesses
that I know you I know the honorable
lady gives a lot of support to I will
write to her listing all those things
and then I will make sure that it is
available on the website of the
department for science Innovation and
Technology Jim Farrell because the the
tech sector in rural Cumbria depends
obviously on reliable broadband and yet
communities in walk up Samford Cooper
and Beck belitan and ormside in
Westmoreland who have signed up to the
community interest company and volunteer
group Barn to provide a gigabit
connection for just 33 pounds a month
but the communities have been suddenly
designated a low priority area meaning
that their vouchers have been removed
putting the whole system and the whole
project at risk I wonder if the minister
would commit the chancellor would it
commit to supporting those communities
and the residents and businesses within
them ensuring that they get the vouchers
that they were initially promised
well I will happily look into what's
happening we strongly support all rural
areas having access to gigabyte
Broadband it's a very important part of
our policy we made a lot of progress in
that area I look into the details of
what's happening in his area and get
back to him bed Lake question number 11
sir
Mr Speaker Hospitality businesses play
an important role in local communities
in the UK economy they benefit from
business rates support worth 13.6
billion pounds over the next five years
which includes an increased generosity
for the retail hospitality and Leisure
relief scheme from 50 to 75 percent in
2023-24 and of course there is our
brexit Pub guarantee which means the
duty on a draft point in a pub will
always be lower than its equivalent in
the supermarket
I'm very grateful to the minister for
that for that answer she will be aware
of course of long-standing uh calls from
the sector for reducing the rate of vat
to bring it in line with uh European
equivalents and would it be possible at
all the treasury turn to take an
assessment of the economic benefits of
doing so and perhaps also consider as a
package
um increasing the threshold for fat
registration from 85 000 pounds to a
hundred thousand pounds to support
smaller businesses
well Mr Speaker
Mike some of which are very complicated
in short in relation to the um that
relief for the hospitality sector it was
really important we did that in the
aftermath of the pandemic but it cost us
a great deal of money and so we've had
to raise it back up to 20 in relation to
other that matters of course we keep
these under review and I'd be delighted
to meet him to discuss some of the
complexities behind this with him
thank you Mr Speaker when I look at the
new job opportunities and career paths
that are being created in pembrokeshire
a great many of those are being created
in the tourism and Hospitality sector
does my honorable friend agree with me
that the very last thing that business
people who are creating those growth
opportunities need right now is a
tourism tax of the kind of being brought
forward by the Welsh labor government in
Cardiff that will hit these businesses
with new burdens and raise the cost for
going on holiday in Wales
well Mr Speaker
in my right-handled friends corner of
pembrokeshire when he speaks up for it
and he's quite right to identify how the
conservatives in government are trying
to help these businesses through our
business rates relief in England through
our energy support scheme over recent
months and of course through the brexit
pub guarantee Welsh labor on the other
hand wants to call last orders and have
higher taxes for those businesses he's
so Keen to support the shadow Minister
thank you Mr Speaker the 2019
conservative Manifesto is some free
Prime Ministers ago and four chancellors
ago promise a fundamental reform of
business rates this is another broken
Tory promise will the minister admit
that only a labor government will end
the chaos scrap business rates and
replace them with a fairer system so
that our amazing Hospitality sector can
Thrive and grow faster really well I
have a great deal of respect for The
Honorable lady I must point out to a
gently that we have in fact conducted
that review and in the Autumn statement
we were able to announce a 13.6 billion
pounds package of help over the next
five years including a multiplier freeze
for all ratepayers large and small a
transitional relief cap for the that is
funded by the exchequer as well as
retail hospitality and Leisure relief
and a small business support scheme
which will help cap Bill increases at
600 pounds per year for businesses
losing eligibility for some or all small
businesses or the rural rate relief for
the 2023 evaluation we've done that
review when we're supporting those
businesses that need the help
question 13 Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker with permission I
would like to answer questions 13 and 22
together advanced economies around the
world are sharing in the challenge of
high inflation from the energy shock and
the UK
and the UK has been affected by these
Global factors
has taken significant action to help
households with Rising Energy prices and
the cost of living by providing a
significant support package totaling 94
billion pounds this includes supporting
households with energy bills by
extending the energy price guarantee and
removing the premium paid by 4 million
households using prepayment meters
overall the government has paid about
half of a typical household Bill since
October 22.
thank you Mr Speaker many people in the
highlands and islands of Scotland will
have their taxes used to help can pay
for the construction of the gas card
despite the fact they are actually off
the gas card themselves and don't
actually get the benefits or been
connected to the gas grid
their area supplies the oil and gas and
now the cheap air new Burns it is
facilitating lower energy bills across
Great Britain but yet these people are
more likely to be fuel power and to rub
salt in the winds many pay a surcharge
on their electricity bills so into UK
government going to address his
inequities yeah well it's very grateful
to The Honorable gentleman I would
simply point out that across the United
Kingdom we've provided extensive support
as I said in my answer to the
substantive I'm very happy to write to
him with details on his specific point
don't do it thank you Mr Speaker when
the energy profits Levy was introduced
to help this government's support of of
household energy bills
uh I welcomed the investment tax
allowance that was introduced along with
it on new oil and gas for energy
Security in recent weeks I also welcomed
the executive secretary announcement in
Aberdeen of a price floor in the form of
an energy security investment mechanism
at which the EPL will be removed the
devil of course will be in the detail
and while I welcome the treasuries and
ongoing engagement and dialogue with the
oil gas industry can I ask the minister
if he will commit to a regular perhaps
quarterly fiscal Forum with the industry
as used to happen prior to covert and
does my honorable friend agree that
Labor's plans to ban all new oil and gas
is based on ideology and not a pragmatic
approach to this country's energy
Security net zero
can I just say I think he ought to put
in for the Germans will be easier for
all of us
we'll miss the Smith
to speak very pleased to meet with
industry leaders and chair of the oil
and gas Forum in Aberdeen uh recently we
had a very good discussion I'm grateful
to the industry for their ongoing
engagement with ministers and officials
I can assure my friend the government is
very committed to engaging with the oil
and gas sector as we have been doing for
a long time number 14.
well uh Mr Speaker as per my previous
response on this same question by The
Honorable gentleman in last treasury
auras I would note that the UK has grown
at a similar rate to comparable European
economy since 2016 and it still remains
challenging to separate out the effects
of brexit and wider Global Trends on the
UK economy but we remain absolutely
committed to seizing the opportunities
that we now have free from the EU
yes it's very convenient only the UK has
to deal with brexit everyone's had to
deal with cool but everyone's had to
deal with Ukraine only the UK has had to
deal with brexit and that's why the lse
says that customers have paid
collectively almost 7 billion pound
extra on their food bills as a direct
result of all the checks and
frustrations that have come with brexit
is she honestly saying that it was a
good idea and that it's not hard at the
UK economy
again I would just gently remind The
Honorable gentleman to
until for example uh the EU zone is
suffering from the effects of mild
recession these are you know these are
because of the global headwinds we are
all facing I know he will be delighted
at the recent upgrades and growth by the
obr the bank of England and the oecd uh
and uh the um the truth is that we Face
these challenges we of course have to
work with our Global counterparts to try
to address these Global headwinds but we
are very much focused on the prime
minister's priority of halving inflation
because that is what will make the real
differences to our constituents John
Burton thank you Mr Speaker does
furthermore does this Minister agree
with me that despite
um project fear forecasts we have record
employment very low unemployment good
inward investment and trade deals and
abundance and perhaps the SMB should
focus on its poor record of on the
economy and indeed Financial
transparency and get over the fact that
we've left the EU
my own room Fred puts it very sex in
clear mayor take this opportunity to
congratulate him on his uh recent honor
um the very well deserved uh he he put
it very succinctly we have a really
exciting future ahead of us we're
already signing trade deals with non-eu
countries we have this fantastic deal
with the EU it's now up to us to make a
real success of course
thank you very much Mr Speaker number
16.
what is that thank you Mr Speaker the
government recognizes the challenges
facing households due to the elevated
costs of living and took further action
at Spring budget this year to provide
targeted support to protect the most
vulnerable this included the new cost of
living payments in this year support
with the cost of Essentials through a
further extension to the household
support Fund in England and upgrading
benefits in line with inflation in April
this year
Mr Speaker I'm most grateful to my
honorable friend for that answer would
she one of the most the best ways to
support those on low incomes is to
remove those barriers that prevent them
from acquiring the new skills that an
essay for better paid jobs can my right
honorable friend confirm that the
treasury is working closely with the
department for education and the DWP to
ensure that lifelong learning Bill gets
rid of those obstacles and can she also
provide an update on the progress of the
barber reviews
well Mr Speaker I know how you like
ministers to answer shortly so if I may
I'll answer the first part and come back
to an on the barber review in writing
first of all my writable friend the
chancellor put employment as one of the
four e's in his uh drive for growth in
the spring budget and we are working
very closely with the department for
education to invest in exactly the way
he describes including free courses for
jobs which enable high-level high value
level three subjects to have free
qualifications and also employer-led
skills boot camps in high growth areas a
phrase I never thought I'd find myself
saying but those are apparently for
sectors such as digital and other growth
sectors available to those who are
unemployed or in work and want to
retrain it's not true
speaker food banks play groups and warm
spaces are among the services that have
been provided by mosques temples
synagogues and churches to all our
constituents to cope with this cost of
living crisis but the buildings they're
in are often creaking and falling apart
so I wondered if ministers would
consider extending Gordon Brown's
original policy for vat relief on
building works for listed places of
worship to all of them to recognize
their role in Social good and
alleviating pressure on multiple systems
The Honorable lady for raising important
point and there has been an incredible
outpouring of support across communities
not just in religious communities but
also in village and town halls around
the United Kingdom to try to help people
with the cost of living pressures that
we're facing over this winter I I
understand the point she makes if I may
it's quite a complicated picture but
perhaps I can write to her with my with
a fuller response on that because I want
to do it justice in my response Mr
Speaker and I know I'll get into trouble
with you question number 17 Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker
the three things the government's doing
to reduce inflation firstly remaining
steadfast in our support of the
independent MPC that the bank of England
as they take action to return inflation
to its Target of two percent secondly
making difficult but responsible
decisions on tax and spending so we're
not adding fuel to the fire and thirdly
tackling High Energy prices by holding
down energy bills for households and
businesses alongside investing in
long-term energy security
thank you Mr Speaker the rich and
Powerful have repeatedly sought to blame
workers for high inflation even though
workers real wages have been falling as
inflation soils but many leading
economists now say the profiteering of
certain corporations is driving price
Rises not wages the French government
has taken action to limit food prices
Spain has introduced rent controls when
will this government start targeting the
profiteering that's helping to drive
inflation yeah Minister well we continue
to have constructive dialogue with
industry in different sectors I met with
the supermarket Representatives a few
weeks ago the chancellor and others in
the treasury will continue to have those
conversations but I think most people
recognize that we Face Global common
challenges and different economies will
respond in different ways
now come to top petals jumper number one
Mr Speaker Chancellor
thank you Mr Speaker we won't hesitate
in our resolve to support the bank of
England as it seeks to strangle
inflation in the economy and the best
policy is to stick to our plan to halve
it but I also want to make sure we do
everything possible to help families
paying higher mortgage rates in ways
that do not themselves feed inflation so
later this week I'll be meeting the
principal mortgage lenders to ask what
help they can give to people struggling
to pay for more expensive mortgages and
what flexibilities might be possible for
families in arrears
thank you Mr Speaker despite being the
gateway to most Financial Services in
the city the London Stock Exchange I
suggest is ailing with crh and R being
the latest canaries in the coal mine
whilst welcoming the Edinburgh reforms
what further consideration has he given
to my suggestion that tax incentives be
introduced to encourage our British
Pension funds the big beasts to invest
more in UK equities given that since the
financial crisis of 2008-9 they've
reduced their exposure to equiters by 90
unlike most other Developers
Chancellor well my honorable friend
always speaks extremely wisely on
financial matters and he's absolutely on
the money when he talks about the
opportunity that presents itself from
unlocking three billion pounds of
pension three trillion pounds of pension
fund assets many of which would get a
better return for pensioners if they
were invested more in our high growth
businesses as well as that being a good
outcome for the London Stock Market and
all I would say to him is watch this
space
shutter Chancellor Rachel leaves
thank you Mr Speaker well the government
squabbble over parties and peerages
mortgage products are being withdrawn
and replaced by mortgages with much
higher interest rates this is a
consequence of the conservative mini
budget last year and 13 years of
economic failure with inflation higher
here than in similar countries average
mortgage payments will be going up by a
crippling 2 900 pounds this year so
where does the chancellor think that
families are going to get the money to
pay the Tory mortgage penalty
but let me tell her that we announced at
the Autumn statement 94 billion pounds
of support to help families going
through very difficult times that was
more support and was ever proposed by
labor but I'll tell her what the answer
to those pressures is not it's not
borrowing an extra 28 billion pounds a
year when people like Paul Johnson are
saying more borrowing means higher
inflation higher interest rates and
higher mortgage rates so Raves it's the
chancellor actually for real this is the
real life consequences of what is
happening under the conservative
government today so don't try and pass
the buck let me bring this home in Selby
and Einstein 12 000 households will be
paying an average of 2 700 pounds more
on their mortgages in Oxbridge and South
ruislip 10 000 households will be paying
on average 5 200 pounds more each and
every family knows who is responsible
for trashing the con the economy it is
the conservative party so will the
chancellor apologize for the harm that
his government have caused with the Tory
mortgage penalty I am proud of our
economic record which has seen
[Applause]
faster than France or Japan since 2010
the same rate as Germany and let me say
that those mortgage holders in Selby or
Uxbridge or mid beverage will be paying
even more for their mortgages if the
government under a labor party borrowed
a hundred billion pounds more in the
next Parliament and we won't let that
happen great Tracy thank you Mr Speaker
and as a minister knows having a strong
Insurance and financial services sector
is vital to the growth of our economy
which is one of the prime minister's
five pledges so can he confirm that he's
doing everything in his powers to make
that happen particularly with a view to
our International competitiveness in
these case sectors
can give my honorable friend the
Assurance he seeks he uh he will know
from his significant contribution to the
financial services and markets bill as
it's gone through this house that it
does introduce a new Duty on our
financial Regulators to promote the
growth in international competitors to
the United Kingdom but alongside that it
also thanks to my honorable friend has
specific reporting measures as to how
they're going to achieve that important
objective
thank you Mr Speaker initially I met
with the minister for schools and
presented them with this costed
proposals over the pilots at the
University School meals in Liverpool the
minister said he wasn't ideologically
opposed to this but that all roles lead
to the today where we are well the
chancellor work with me and the minister
to enable his Pilot which would
transform the Education Health and
well-being of thousands of children
across my great City
who wants a chance I'll happily uh write
him to talk to him about that particular
initiative what I would say to him is we
are making great progress in our schools
we've risen to fourth in the global
League tables when it comes to reading
but we can always do more so David Evan
thank you Mr Speaker can I welcome my
right honorable friend's commitment to
making inflation and the cost of living
his top priority this is also our top
priority of my constituents in Bexley
Heath and Craven does my ride-on friend
agree with me that the ifs is entirely
correct that Labor's plans for 28
billion pounds of borrowing in their
green Prosperity plan would simply lead
to higher rates of interest and higher
inflation yeah Chancellor
my writable friend is absolutely right
the answer to inflation is to tackle it
not to make it worse
thank you Mr Speaker wages in real terms
or lower now than what they were in 2008
it's an absolute disgrace Mr Speaker the
Northeast has been hit they're harder
than other regions and worst of all for
child poverty their child poverty rates
have shut up resultant in 67 percent of
children and work and families living in
poverty there's a chancellor has
deliberate brutal policy of weird
suppression working if sir who for
Chancellor
let me say to The Honorable gentleman
that we understand the pressures that
families are going through up and down
the country but we have responded not
only with generous support this year and
last of over three thousand pounds for
the average household but since 2010 the
number of children in absolute poverty
has fallen by 400 000.
paying around half the cost of people's
energy bills and freezing fuel Duty has
been crucial in helping people with the
cost of living but is there further
action the government can take to get
inflation down and are we on track to
halve it by the end of the year
it's a Relentless activity to control
public spending and to ensure that the
interventions we're making prioritize
growth enablement the household support
fund of two and a half billion continues
to be an additional source of support
for households but there aren't quick
fixes there is a Relentless pursuit of
the goals that we've set out to start
this year
Russell thank you Mr Speaker how on
Earth can the chancellor begin to
understand the worries of ordinary
homeowners well in 2018 it had seemedly
slipped his mind to declare that he had
spent three and a half million pounds
buying seven luxury Flats as an
investment opportunity in Southampton
isn't it reality Mr Speaker that him and
the treasury front bench are completely
out of touch what homeowners homeowners
are facing
with respects to the honor judgment I
think he should get his facts right
before making that kind of suggestion he
got them wrong
Mr Speaker in-person banking facilities
are vitally important to everyone in
South and West yet in recent years we've
lost all but one of our bank branches
there's now a new community-based post
office banking Hub model being rolled
out so would the minister support my
efforts to get one of these into Leon
sea
yes I thank the uh I think you're a
woman for a question uh she will know
that as part of the financial services
and markets but I can update the house
that the government's moved an amendment
to protect free access to cash
withdrawal and deposit facility uh but
I'd be very happy to meet with my
honorable friend to discuss her own
individual constituencies needs others
to go vital thank you Mr Speaker I
remain the host of my internal register
of members interests and government
recent pronouncements relation to food
security have been very welcome but if
they are to be meaningful then farmers
and Crafters need certainty about the
future state of government support and
critically the amount of money that will
be available to fund that so can the
chancellor tell us when he will engage
with defra in the devolved
administrations about the size of the of
the budget that will be available and If
in the meantime he would meet with me in
the nfus
well as he knows that the the farming
support payment is
ported to Scotland and it operates on a
different basis because it's devolved
and we've committed to the 2.4 billion
for the duration of this Parliament and
there are a number of schemes that where
the uptake is now increasing I will
continue to engage with my colleagues
from defra as those schemes develop
further Larry Robinson Mr Speaker of the
lust Bank in the entirety of Cheadle
constituency is about to close so I was
delighted when following my
interventions and direct conversations
with link and appeals from the community
that Bram always links 100th banking Hub
recommendation this will be invaluable
for residents but until it opens my
residents will be left without banking
services would my honorable friends look
please look into bridging options for
the interim between Bank closures and
hub openings or consider imposing
requirements for banks to remain open
until a pub a hub is implemented
I'll be very happy to meet with my
honorable friend to talk about the range
of options I'm delighted about the
solution that is being proposed for
Bramble in her own constituency as I was
to visit the new banking Hub in the
constituency The Honorable member for
healing act Central and Acton last week
and I hope the whole house would wish
the operator VIP varsani well in that
new endeavor
Sir Christopher Brian thank you Mr
Speaker for the first time in my 20
years as an MP we have a real housing
crisis in the wrong the two-thirds of
people own their own homes but lots of
people who've relied on the commercial
rented sector are finding that landlords
because of decisions made about taxation
are selling their properties and because
there's a cap on the housing benefit
they're not wanting to continue in that
market we have dozens of people being
evicted week in week out at the moment
will the government please look very
closely it's what what is happening in
constituencies such as mine to protect
people so that they can keep their own
home
oh that history I'm very happy to meet
uh with the honorable gentleman to
discuss what's happening is constituency
obviously there have been a series of
changes since the section 24 change in
the finance act in in 2015 and obviously
particular pressures uh in the housing
economy at the moment but are happy to
meet them discuss it further thank you
very much Mr Speaker I welcome the work
that the chancellor and prime minister
have done to promote the work here of
artificial intelligence and developing
an ecosystem for that it's clear that
the UK has got an opportunity to really
lead on this especially on regulation if
we get it right but only if we seize
that opportunity now what's the chance
they're doing to make that happen
Chancellor well my rightover friend is
right to say this is a big opportunity
we're home to a third of Europe's AI
startups but we are very aware of the
risks of AI so what the government is
doing is hosting a global AI Summit with
the supporter President Biden this
Autumn to make sure we get that
regulation absolutely right Samuels
thank you Mr Speaker
quite rightly the this question time has
been dominated by questions on inflation
and cost of living but one policy which
has not been mentioned is the
government's Net Zero policy and the
inflationary costs included in it from
Green levees of 12 billion to the cost
of strengthening the infrastructure and
also the favorable treatment to
renewable energy firms while the
minister May condemn the labor party for
29 billion
expanding on on green on green Air
policies what is the cost of zero Net
Zero policies to Consumers and is it not
picking their pockets dry
well Mr Speaker we have a world leading
track record on Net Zero but we have to
have a right of the correct balance
between uh who Bears the costs and the
critical to uh the nature of his
question is mobilizing more private
capital and we are making great strides
on that point Peter Gibson Mr Speaker
can my right honorable friend update the
house as to when we will see Spades in
the ground on the Brunswick site in
Darlington for the Darlington economic
campus
my honorable friend is a great Champion
for Darlington and darlington's economic
campus is a critical part of leveling up
the government property agency uh have
been working hard to finalize commercial
negotiations and I'm very happy to write
to my old friend when I have a more
substantive update
Mr speaker ever increase in food prices
mean that some families are having to
cut down on the amount they eat so will
the minister support Labor's plan to
negotiate a new Veterinary agreement for
agriculture products to reduce the cost
for food producers and bring down those
crippling food prices
who wants chance
we'll always look at Labor policies but
they're normally not right
thank you Mr Speaker clear policy uh
clear policy Direction and a strong
regulatory framework has led to the UK
being the world's leading Center in
fintech does my honorable friend agree
that uh the the crypto uh industry
offers the same opportunity to the UK to
exploit
Mr
friend is absolutely right I was pleased
to join him in a Westminster Hall debate
about the regulation of the crypto asset
sector I commend the work done in this
house by the all-party Parliamentary
group on crypto assets and he might join
me in welcoming the decision by
Andreessen Horowitz one of the world's
largest technology companies to locate
their only International office outside
of San Francisco here in the UK and to
run their 2024 crypto asset school here
exercise cygnus in 2016 tested the
country's preparedness for a a pandemic
was the government's response at that
time adequate and what can he do in his
current role to make sure that we're
properly prepared in the future
Chancellor well I will I am looking
forward to answering questions about
that tomorrow afternoon at the covert
inquiry um what I would say to him is
that I think we did what was recommended
following operation cygnus certainly
ministers did what they were advised to
do but it was focused on pandemic flu
and the question we have to ask
ourselves is why we didn't have a
broader focus on the different types of
pandemic that could have happened such
as covert
thank you Mr Speaker the government's
business rates review last Autumn was
anything but fundamental because it
didn't even look at the calculations for
fair and maintainable trade which are
hammering the viability of pubs instant
Albans so if the chancellor has in fact
abandoned his commitment for a
fundamental review of business rates
which he himself called for last summer
will he at least look at the
calculations for fair and maintainable
trade before any more of our valuable
pubs have to close yeah
as I say we did we conducted a review
and we had the 13.6 billion pounds
package of support to help businesses on
our high streets if she's able to look
at for example the multiplier freeze
that has a significant impact on those
rates as does the retail hospitality and
Leisure relief which will help raise the
rate of relief from 50 to 75 we've
targeted this very carefully of exactly
the businesses she's raising I'll treat
because the chancellor was shaking his
head during my question earlier on so I
wonder if he can see whether or not he
accepts the findings from the London
School of economic Center for economic
performance that shows that brexit is
responsible for a third of UK price
inflation since 2019 regulatory sanitary
and other border checks added almost 7
billion pound it's a total domestic
grocery bills over the period from
December 2019 to March 2023 does he
accept that or not
Jim Shannon
right let's move on